A good example of
what a WHY sounds like
I'll tell you a story
I did some work with the Disney Imagineers
these are the people who
build all the rides,
design all the parades,
all the shows, the boats,
everything like that.
Everything that's not a movie or
merchandising basically
the Imagineers
invent it, build it, design it.
And I was giving a talk about
the WHY
and the Golden Circle to the Imagineers
and somebody asked the same question
which is
"Can you give us an example of
what a WHY looks like
or sounds like?"
So I picked a random person
in the audience
and I asked him to give me
a specific story
that helps me understand,
that really captures
what he loves
about being an Imagineer.
And he told a story
you have to appreciate
that he told over the course of
seven minutes maybe
basically of how he was the
lead engineer on a ride
and he went to
I should preempt with,
I should tell you this
that he didn't know this
and I found out later
that his nickname at the office was
"ice chips"
because he was cold and everything
well he's an engineer
so everything was exact
and just sort of not the most
emotional guy
so they called him Ice Chips
this was his nickname behind his back.
So I called on Ice Chips by accident and
he told the story of how
there was a new ride that was opening
that he was the lead engineer and
he saw a guy in a wheelchair
and his daughter
heading towards the ride
to try it out for the first time
and one of
the things that occurred to him was that
anywhere else in the world
people see
a guy in a wheelchair with his daughter.
Only at Disneyland
the only thing people see
is a father and his daughter
going to Disneyland.
And and he says
that's what it means to him
to work for this organization.
That it's about parents and children
and family
and brothers and sisters
and boyfriends and girlfriends
and husbands and wives and
every combination of family
that we can come up with
and that's all there is
just those relationships.
And that's why
everything was so exact to him.
And in an instant we're all crying
and it was a beautiful story
but in an instant
everybody understood
why he was always so hard about everything
because to him
those were the stakes.
They had to make things
that made people feel
that they were just a father and a daughter
that nothing else mattered.
It was pretty amazing.
And it gave everybody context
everybody fell in love with him that day.